[Music]
you have had an incredible year and then
it culminates in in in hosting the
Oscars now a year ago this time is the
second time you've said it aloud and I
don't like it cuz it makes it real well
you have to get used to being really yes
if I decide at the last minute that you
know this wasn't such a good idea let's
back out you know you've already said it
on TV oh yeah this is really binding
here no no a year ago this time you were
hosting the Charlie Sheen roast yes if
some time out seriously now if someone
told you a year ago yes now you're
hosting the show change a year from now
will be the Oscars with Plaza it's as
well it's what happened Ikaros right
rose too far too fast
was it Icarus or was it his kid no it
was it current okay Icarus got too close
to the Sun his wings made of Wagner the
Harvard guy I don't know when I'm
talking yeah but it it was the Harvard
driving school mastered in parallel
parking billion-plus I know it's crazy
tonight there's nothing we can do on
this show once but you just put it back
the way I can't I can't help it but
thanks for touching it a billion plus
viewers on the on yes that's what they
tell me now you got to think obviously
you're very popular with a lot of young
people but not all the viewers watching
globally are probably going to know who
you I would say most probably won't know
I would I you know I mean we feel like
95% will go who's that guy right yeah
well I don't know they might you know
people watching around the world might
you might walk out they may think I
don't know who that is yeah yeah we
agree on this who are you I'm curious
who will you be mistaken for uh I you
know I think I'll be mistaken for Chris
Rock if anybody
what would Stewie say about you hosting
who the hell do you think you are do you
ever you your show can be quite rough on
celebrities and we do it occasionally
too I don't know if you're but you
really you really can go after some
slippers every afraid like you'll be
hosting the Oscars you're gonna see a
lot of celebrities bumping into people
that you've torn apart on your show Hey
right that's all of them I think yeah so
how is that is that something you ever
worry about you get nervous about you
know if I see the Helen Mirren coming at
me with a steak knife I'm gonna know to
get out of the way right just move just
go yeah thank for example Tom Cruise you
portrayed him as a gay kidnapper
yeah now maybe he's feeling yeah we know
what you did to Helen Mirren it I know
Thomas is fine with us what we did to
Helen Mirren yeah that's that yeah
that's where we're gonna get in trouble
yeah we did do that didn't we
yeah don't include me yes we did you
called me up and I said do it and put my
name on it
when you pitched me that joke I said
that can't go in the show and you
insisted and I said come and we don't
even work together and and I never got
paid you uh you did stand-up in college
didn't I did yeah I did a little bit of
stand-up did you uh did you was it jokes
or did you do voices and I would imagine
we did voices it was a little of both
yeah it was it was you know it was Regan
there was Nixon it was all really
current impressions sure Joe eat that
stuff oh yeah WC Fields they loved it
yeah like Clinton was I would guess in
the 90s would be it yeah yeah yeah that
was yeah I met Clinton actually at a
Democratic Party fundraiser I mean I'm
not affiliated with either party but I
happened to be at a Democratic Party
fundraiser
right and was open bar yeah yeah I was
there I was you came into the window
yeah I'm a fun playful drunk like that
selling flavor but and and they should
be prepared for the for the power of his
charisma like be prepared for you know
he gets overwhelming and he introduced
me to him and said mr. president this is
Seth MacFarlane he does a show called
Family Guy and and Clinton says oh yeah
I haven't I haven't ever seen the show
but I heard about it's good it's good
show come on here I'll tell you what I
love is that Grey's Anatomy respond I am
overwhelmed right now
what a charming thing the item a
charming fellow